you know everyone's like bro this guy
didn't take a picture with me at a
convention this YouTube is an [ __ ]
but have you heard the stories about
Harrison Ford with fans no no he's
[ __ ] mean like he I swear there's so
many [ __ ] stories I gotta look them
up there's so many [ __ ] it just seems
like an [ __ ] I I don't you know
there's actors that you can Envision
being at a fan meeting and like having a
really positive experience yeah like you
know uh I don't know Tom Hiddleston or
something right and then there are
people they just like I could never
imagine you being at a concept but but
the thing is if if even if you have a
negative experience at Harrison Ford in
my mind that's still a positive
experience because you've got to meet
Aaron no no because because I'm like yo
Harrison Ford told me to [ __ ] off so in
character man that's exactly what I
expect from Harrison Ford online it's
just certainly like oh he sees his fans
as customers but not in like an
insulting word it's just like how he
views it which I obviously I can in some
senses I'm like I respect you to just be
like yeah [ __ ] it yeah you're all
customers [ __ ] it's not beating around
the [ __ ] yeah but I think he hates
Star Wars fans like I if you I think he
like legitimately doesn't like Star Wars
I probably would hate Star Wars fans too
if I was Harrison honestly and I I in my
mind I'm like yeah I could I could
definitely understandable yeah
understand yo especially like OG Star
Wars fans you know the OG days where
Star Wars just became a popular [ __ ]
Mega hit imagine going to conventions
and actually just meeting Comic Book Guy
except it's not like a parody it's like
it's actually just Comic Book Guy you
know he's done like so many films in
like how many goddamn years and for the
past 40 years he's he's [ __ ] his
handsome that's that's and that must
drive I would drive anyone crazy yeah
he's Han Solo and Indiana Jones right
yeah apparently and then people forget
that he was in I don't know like [ __ ]
uh but one of the Articles was like why
does Harrison Ford hate Star Wars fans
are not Indiana Jones fans well because
Indiana Jones fans on his rabid I mean
they're normies yeah
right I mean I mean Star Wars fans are
also there's different level of Star
Wars fans there's the Casual Star Wars
fan there's always a casual I just like
the Lego games and yeah that was good
yeah there's lots of interesting things
about Star Wars definitely no it's weird
now because it feels like Star Wars it
used to be just Star Wars was just the
mainline film Trilogy that was it that
was that was like the only way to really
enjoy Star Wars but now there's so much
Star Wars meteor out there that I don't
even know where to start because Disney
paid a lot of money and they want them
no exactly they want that [ __ ] money
back yeah they're gonna milk every
goddamn facet of Star Wars yeah this is
just the beginning I think I think we're
in like phase one of their like phase
one of their like 20 face I'm I'm
waiting Star Wars milking project I'm
waiting for a Chewbacca backstory movie
uh it's well we're gonna if we haven't
had one already I'm telling you here's
what's gonna happen clip this in five
years when it becomes relevant yeah it's
gonna be an animation movie of Chewbacca
where it's like all cutesy and Chewbacca
doesn't really talk and it's gonna be
like a silent movie and they're gonna
merchandise the [ __ ] out of it there's
gonna be baby
it's gonna be like a silent anime
[Applause]
because they learned from baby Yoda and
they're like if we just make it like a
kind of Minion Vibe yeah they're gonna
attend Chewbacca into minions and I'm
telling you there's nothing you can do
about it and it's gonna happen oh my God
it's like me yeah this is gonna happen
I'm telling you it's like minions and
Furbies and when it happens come back to
this trash Test episode and be like wow
this aged amazingly oh poorly depending
on what poorly yeah good or good old
Disney there's no way they're doing
something with Chewbacca's right as a
Chewbacca movie and you're not making it
animated yeah think about it the suits
look too ugly
not not marketable enough for kids
that's true it's like look look what
they did with uh like the the recent
Disney remakes where they're remaking
old classics
yeah like Beauty and the Beast and stuff
yeah I hate that [ __ ] I know right like
have you have you guys has anyone seen
like The Lion King or anything yeah
that's all what I forgot about that I
saw it in cinemas I blocked that from my
memory I started Cinemas because I was
just I mean [ __ ] love Lion King so I
was just like I am just morbidly curious
if this is even gonna be remotely good
it was the most like if I could just
like I've never met a movie I've never
seen a movie and just immediately
thought uncanny valley yeah like I don't
I'm like I don't know I'm not a fan of
lions smiling that was because they made
the lines look realistic yeah it's it's
like that you know before they also kind
of gave them human emotional faces as
well so it's like there's just like
lions green and like scolding and [ __ ]
I'm just like lions don't do that well
it's kind of it's kind of like you know
when and before Paramount fixed the
Sonic movie do you remember like the
first Sonic trailer where you had like
[ __ ] teeth and it just looked like a
[ __ ] lovecraftian nightmare creatures
and [ __ ] like that you know it's like a
Thor yeah right
yeah yeah because like I watched like a
few clips of Aladdin and I'm just like
damn obviously now it's called Hey on
Will Smith and everything but um he just
like you can't replace Robin Williams as
a genie like Will Smith Will Smith was
the charismatic guy although to be fair
the only redeemable Factor about that
movie is Will Smith let's not forget
let's move lion oh I didn't even bother
watching oh yeah I did did you watch it
no it was but like I mean I mean it got
absolutely [ __ ] it was it was like it
was it was bound to fail before it even
came out of course there's a [ __ ] ton of
controversies yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
just like every single live action
they've touched as like either boring or
just actually [ __ ] yeah like Beauty and
the Beast was probably the one where I'm
just like okay I can see this kind of
working and I watched it I'm like okay
it wasn't [ __ ] horrible but I would
much rather just watch the original I
watched 30 minutes of it on a plane and
like I was like I can't yeah I'll keep
watching it yeah I don't know I just a
lot of the Disney movies is like all
right okay I think I think hit me up and
take my money yeah I think it was Beauty
and the Beast they just like they kind
of just like use the [ __ ] smoke just
just rob me I'm [ __ ] tired of Disney
like shutting out an intricate trap to
make everyone go and spend their money
just rob me just [ __ ] take my money I
don't care anymore all these movies suck
I know I know they suck they do they do
no they own everything no didn't they
also do a live-action Jungle Book as
well yeah they did yeah I didn't I
didn't watch that no I didn't watch that
either I I mean didn't hear a lot about
it what Unforgettable they make their
money and they die yeah that's true what
I never understand right is that there's
this mentality where you know you have a
you have an animated film like Jungle
Book like Lion King talking but it
doesn't become legitimized I guess until
you make it in live actually yeah and
it's not just it's not just you know
Disney cartoons as well we can say the
same thing
we're just like okay and anime's made it
one it's got a live action adaptation
but like The Jungle Book and the uh Lion
King there's so much animation well I'd
argue it's more of an animation
you just animated it in a realistic yeah
with Lion King it's like 100 CGS it's
CGI like I'm not watching an IRL thing
this is just a [ __ ] risky yeah this is
like the The Uncanny Valley rescape yeah
it is [ __ ] yeah should make something
new for fun it's like Lion King was made
by Ai and it's just like one one thing I
never understood was like why is there
not more of the opposite sense remaking
popular live action films in animation
because I feel like the only one that's
really notable is Spider-Man well it's
because it's because Hollywood doesn't
take despite of us yeah yeah I mean but
I feel Hollywood doesn't take animation
seriously unless it's Marvel in DC or
pixel
yeah yeah I mean everything else is just
like it's it's not a real I mean I don't
really count Spider-Man because
Spider-Man is a comic to begin with and
you know there's had plenty of like
cartoon so you're saying something that
has never had any kind of animated like
iteration of it yeah yeah I mean okay
look I see things like you know one of
the only Star Wars media I like is Star
Wars Visions right because Star Wars
Clone Wars Star Wars clone was [ __ ]
hype that was hype you know the anime
tricks does anyone remember the
animatrix of [ __ ] man and that's because
there's like when you i i s like I in my
opinion when you take something that's
animated and translate that into live
action you are actually restricting a
lot of the expression that you can get
away with right because you're taking
something that in a lot of times is
taking place in like a very Fantastical
world where it's not limited by you know
reality you know by the chains of
reality I guess right but when you take
a live something live action and put in
animation you have so many more ideas
for just so many so many more
opportunities
key ideas and just wacky visuals and all
that kind of stuff right well that's why
like a lot of the even the modern Pixar
films are just like still you know
creatively like you know sufficient
because it's like yeah as you were
saying it's like you can't have
something like [ __ ] Moana in live
action just because like a lot of those
scenes are just like not going to work
or or they're gonna look really [ __ ]
attack I haven't had to stop my brain
the whole time like I've seen a lot of
live actions porn
I've seen a lot of these things in life
oh oh oh oh yeah you've seen that you've
seen the dozens yeah the live action
translates well to live
actions
yeah did you see like any did you see
like the Halo anime or like the Mass
Effect I heard so bad the Halo uh TV
show yeah I heard they question it is as
well is there an anime for Halo yeah
there's like uh there's Halo Legends
which is which is kind of like the same
kind of taking this franchise and making
like an anthology series of just right
different things about it right I've
I've not actually watched Halo Legends
I've heard it's I've heard mixed things
about it right but it's funny because I
remember watching Star Wars visions and
nothing made me more happy than watching
Star Wars visions and just seeing OG
Star Wars map or OG Star Wars fan just
[ __ ] mold oh you're in the reviews if
you if you go out and read the IG uh I
don't know IMDb reviews of Star Wars
Visions it is so [ __ ] hilarious
because everything they hate Star Wars
Visions for is everything that I love
Star Wars videos yeah it's just
completely different they're like this
isn't this doesn't go along with the
Star Wars Universe they're just using
the force like it's a [ __ ] thing oh
you know the force has rules we we have
we have boundaries here well I think
like the Star Wars Vision showed me that
oh yeah there's so many more other cool
interesting Concepts that you could do
with Star Wars yeah than the current
Star Wars universe exactly the samurai
one that was [ __ ] hyped
[ __ ] that that first episode with the
samurai where she comes out with this
[ __ ] lightsaber umbrella yeah that's
just cool that's cool [ __ ] man you
haven't watched it check it out yeah
it's pretty good it's very interesting
if you want to see Star Wars like sick
then yeah
Star Wars alpha Disney for making
something good
yeah that's that's the thing I'm not I
wouldn't say I'm a Star Wars fan but
there's plenty of Star Wars things that
I like uh yeah but I do agree like I do
hate how underappreciated just animation
has become in Hollywood unless again
it's not Disney or Pixar or no what what
thing has Disney done recently well
that's what I'm saying they don't even
do animations
yeah yeah turning Reds oh is that the
one with the the red panda yeah yeah
okay I haven't seen that one you know
the main voice actress watches trash
text for that movie really really
actually does shout out to you
I love that movie do you actually
I haven't seen it
oh now though
I just posted the plush of uh because we
won one of them in the crank game videos
yeah and she posted I'm forgetting the
name I should I should know your name I
apologize yeah uh she posted this she
said oh my God I want it and then
everything was like that's the main
voice actress for the the character oh
cool I was like oh thanks for watching
the video she's like oh I watch Trash
taste too and I was like what the [ __ ]
um I can't remember uh yeah I don't know
yeah yeah
um you on screen right now turning right
um what were you saying before that I
forgot if anyone was the latest movie
turning red there was enchanto Encanto
yeah and then they had Encanto and then
I got confused because there was Encanto
on the other
movie that came out right before which
was the other one that was an encounter
about another uh which one said can't
talk yeah there's two of them there's a
one that we're about death
you if you've not seen encounter it's
the one where you there's like stuff
yeah we don't talk about Bruno you must
have heard that
I think I couldn't escape for a while
yeah basically yeah it's like you you
haven't seen Encanto but you know you
know you know in cancer okay Coco
there's Coco and in Canada oh I watch
cocoa